AUTHORITARIANISM.
THEIR MOTTO IS DO WHAT WE TELL
YOU OR HATE DEMOCRACY.
HOW IS THAT FOR YOU?
THIS COUNTRY IS SAID TO HAVE ITS
NEXT CENSUS IN 2020.
WE HAVE TO EVERY TEN YEARS.
UNLESS POLICIES CHANGE, THE
CENSUS WILL BE COUNTING ILLEGAL
ALIENS THE SAME AS EVERYBODY
ELSE.
THE CITIZENS HASN'T ASKED ABOUT
CITIZEN STATUS SINCE 1950, SO A
LOT OF PEOPLE GET A BOOST OF
REPRESENTATION BECAUSE OF THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN FOR STATE.
THIS IS A PROBLEM.
IT'S NOT DEMOCRATIC.
IT IS TIME TO CHANGE THAT AND HE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
THE SECRETARY, THANK YOU FOR
COMING ON.
THE CONSTITUTION SAYS YOU HAVE
TO HAVE A CENSUS.
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHOSE
INFORMATION MATTERS ARE
CITIZENS.
IT MATTERS WHETHER CITIZENS ARE.
>> THINK OF IT THIS WAY, THERE
SEVERAL HUNDRED 10,000 PEOPLE
WHO ARE REPRESENTED IN CONGRESS.
IF YOU LIVE IN I DISTRICT OR
MAXINE WATERS IS, HALF OR MORE
OF YOUR DISTRICT IS PROBABLY
ILLEGAL ALIENS.
WE MAY HAVE 350 CITIZENS VOTING
IN YOUR DISTRICT, AND THOSE
CITIZENS POST COUNTS TWICE AS
MUCH THAT MY VOTE FOR YOUR VOTE
IN A DISTRICT THAT DOESN'T HAVE
TONS OF ILLEGAL ALIENS.
YOUR VOTE DILUTION WERE SOME
PEOPLE'S VOTES MATTER MORE THAN
OTHERS BECAUSE IF THEY HAVE TONS
OF ILLEGAL ALIENS.
>> Tucker: THE LIBERALS ARE
ALWAYS YELLING ABOUT HOW EVERY
VOTE COUNTS IN EVERY VOTE SHOULD
MATTER THE SAME AS ANY OTHER
BOAT.
WHY WOULD THEY BE FOR THIS?
>> I THINK IT'S A DIRTY LITTLE
SECRET THEY DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THE 1964 DECISION OF THE
SUPREME COURT VOTING DELUSION IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
YOU CAN'T HAVE ONE CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT WHERE THERE ARE FEWER
VOTERS THAN THERE ARE IN ANOTHER
DISTRICT.
BECAUSE OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION,
WE HAVE CRAZY DISPROPORTION.
YOU HAD IT 120,000 VOTES TO WIN
BACK YOUR ELECTION.
AND ANOTHER, YOU MIGHT JUST NEED
300.
>> Tucker: THE ANSWER IS
REALLY SIMPLE, CHECK A BOX, ARE
YOU A CITIZEN OR NOT?
ARE YOU ALLOWED TO VOTE LEGALLY?
WHAT'S THE ARGUMENT AGAINST
THAT?
>> THE ONLY ARGUMENT I'VE HEARD
IS A REALLY LAME ONE.
THEY SAID PEOPLE WOULD BE AFRAID
TO ANSWER THE CENSUS FOR IF IT
ASKED THE CITIZENS OR QUESTION.
IS RIDICULOUS.
WE ALREADY AFTER THE CITIZENS
QUESTION ON THE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY SURVEY, WHICH ABOUT 1%
OF THE POPULATION GETS.
THE DEMOCRATS NEVER COMPLAINED
ABOUT THAT.
ONLY WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
CITIZENSHIP STATUS ON THE CENSUS
TO THE LEFT START.
>> Tucker: WHY SHOULD WE CARE
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T ALLOWED TO
VOTE IN OUR ELECTIONS IS
SUPPOSED TO ANSWER A CENSUS?
>> IF YOU ARE ILLEGALLY IN THIS
COUNTRY, WE SHOULDN'T BE
CONSIDERING YOU A RESIDENT
ANYWAY.
YOU CAN LEAVE AND GO HOME ANY
DAY.
YOU COULD BE DEPORTED AND GO
HOME.
WHY IN THE WORLD WILL BE BE
WORRIED ABOUT THEM?
>> Tucker: WHY WOULD YOUR
FEELINGS MATTER MORE THAN A FAIR
ELECTION?
>> IT'S NOT JUST FAIR ELECTION.
GOVERNMENT NEEDS THIS
INFORMATION.
WE CAN'T ACCURATELY COUNT THE
REGISTRATION RATE.
UNLESS I KNOW HOW MANY CITIZENS
I HAVE.